Mallory I know you're new to the LA area
and I saw that you had something on your
blog about like networking and you put
networking is like kissing can you
explain I think networking is just like
kissing because it's something that
everybody else seems to know how to do
but you they can't explain it to you how
to do it something that you just have to
do by doing but it's also very very
important and unlike kissing networking
is incredibly important for the creative
person to learn how to do and know how
to do and be able to balance being able
to promote yourself but also being
polite and being able to work with other
people and for some people that's a hard
line to walk think on your blog you'd
said something about you know business
cards and it's better to not just may be
present it right away but first connect
with the person oh definitely i really
think that the only time it's
appropriate to give somebody a business
card give something a link to a short
film you've done your any sort of
business handover you have to have a
connection with that person it's
important to my rule with networking and
with most interactions with people that
you don't know especially business stuff
is be interested and also interesting
it's a 50-50 and there's if you're
talking to someone and you're really
excited about your project you also have
to remember that they're here for a
reason and they want to tell you about
their project so you want to be talking
as much as you are listening and after
you've had a really good connection with
someone you've talked about what you
want to do then I think is the time to
say hey I really enjoyed talking to you
here's my business card please email me
here's a vimeo link to a short i've done
if you want to see it that way it
doesn't feel intrusive and that way
someone remembers you a lot of i'm sure
everybody's had this experience after a
networking event you have all these
business cards and you don't remember
who gave them to you because there was
no connection to go along with them but
if you've talked to somebody and you if
they've made some sort of impression on
you then you can remember oh this is the
person that i had that great
conversation about you know lighting
with and and that is a basis to form a
business relationship on you have to
create some sort of foundation first
what about a serial connector but then
they don't follow up I see a lot of that
sometime
and what's your answer for that for
someone who seems to want to connect you
follow up with them and then you don't
hear anything back or you do and it's
like a few weeks later and it's not
clear on it with people like that I just
don't even worry about it I don't have
time for people like that you just move
on just move on I mean if it's if it's a
connection that you really really want
you might want to pursue it a little bit
but generally if I really am firmly of
the camp that if you aren't getting some
sort of strange feeling from somebody
and you aren't don't have a strong
connection with them it's probably not
going to work in that that uneasiness is
probably going to continue throughout
the business relationship that you try
to create with them you also say don't
drink too much and networking events
which is funny because you want to be
relaxed but like that's the other thing
that you need to balance is that you you
want to be participating with everybody
you want to have fun you you know but
you also need to keep your head and
people are watching that stuff and
especially in the creative world there's
a lot of people that overindulge and I
know people that have rules of that oh I
don't want to work with anyone who
drinks too much so you again balance
you